Britney Spears life is pretty good right
now her new album drops tomorrow she's
returning to the VMAs this weekend but
then this bombshell dropped lifetime is
making an unauthorized movie about her
life and it is clear Britt Britt is not
happy about it
lifetime announced the new Britney movie
and praised the pop princess calling her
a quote timeless force in entertainment
oh but Britney isn't having it her rep
tells us quote Britney Spears will not
be contributing in any way shape or form
to the lifetime biopic nor does it have
her blessing production gets underway
next month in Vancouver and the movie
will air next year on lifetime so who's
playing Britney well the part is going
to a relatively unknown Australian
actress her name is Natasha Bassett and
she had a small part in George Clooney's
recent film Hail Caesar don't think a
few pinches have a few laughs of course
Britney's lifetime biopic isn't the
first to spark controversy Whitney
Houston's family objected to lifetimes
movie about her and so did relatives of
the singer Aaliyah in 2014 as for
Britney well let's just say lifetime has
plenty of material this 34 year old has
been through a lot I'm really
overwhelming right now and et has been
there for all of it she dated Justin
Timberlake we have fun we love what
we're doing it has been married twice to
dancer Kevin Federline and for 55 hours
to childhood friend Jason Alexander I
wanted to do something wild and crazy
and um I wanted to get married so that's
why I did it
Erin Louis Britney was the tabloid
target she's now moved on to her
successful Vegas residency and her
happiest role proud loving mom my main
thing is to enjoy life and take today
take one day at a time and I try to live
by that and it kind of is kind of cool